COACH.
SAN MAKE A
AND FIRST-ROUND PICK
2003.
DREW DOWDY,
PETERSEN.>> PREPARE LIKE YOU AR
DURZI AND LAST
SECOND RIPPED SHOT BUT MAY
HAVE BEEN STICK
AND GOES OVER THE LEFT SHOULDER
>> THE YEAR.
>> MALKIN OPTI CHANGES
THINGS.
>> WORKINTHE BOARDS AND COMES O
I LOVE THE BACK CHCHAND THE KIN
BACK ON TOP.
BACK HAND AND SCORE SHORT SIDE.
LETANG WITH THE STICK LOW AND
DUMOULIN
A BREAK AWAY.
THE ICE IN THE
HE SCORES.
FO ON FOUR GOALS.
IT IS CRACK
THERE BY DOUGHTY. HAVE IN THE
FIRST PERIOD IN
THE FACEOFF CIRCLE.
GOING AGAINST THE LA KINGS.
MALKIN HAS IT WHEN HE RAINS IT
THE D HE SCORES.
BRIAN RUST.
WE  AS RUST PICKS THE PUCK
UP.
CROSBY IN FRONT
OF THE BY LIZOTTE.
AND ANOTHER GOAL FOR TREVOR
MOPICK KOPITAR.
PASSING PUCK TOWARDS JARRY.
LETANG.
SPEED THERE. PING IN.
GOING BACK TO DURZI.
AND SPRAWLING ALL
OVER JARRY